I'm Zack Harvey of Lama su Bitcoin
ventures and we are the creators of the
Bitcoin machine which is cash to Bitcoin
in under 10 seconds if you just want to
try it out without losing too much just
try to see what it feels like to have
some bitcoins this is the easiest way to
go all you need is the QR code which
represents where the money is going your
address once you have that it'll look
something like this and when I press
start on the machine that's the first
thing it's going to want to know where
do I send the money I then scan it into
the machine now it wants me to insert a
bill so I'm taking a low denomination
five-pound bill I can either keep
putting more in or press send Bitcoin
and boom I got it with this it's just
like a cash so I don't need to know the
identity doesn't matter all I'm really
showing the machine is my QR code our
machine is unique in the sense that it
doesn't require any connection to a bank
we don't have to sign up with the bank
the banks don't have to take any risks
with dealing with Bitcoin because we're
not working with them